for movies that deserve a second chance
two films that were so underrated that
you might not have even heard of them
we've rounded up a selection of
superhero films from the past 15 years
that don't receive much acclaim but may
be worth a rewatch hitting theaters less
than two months after Christopher
Nolan's critically acclaimed Batman
Begins in 2005 sky high offers a very
different take on superheroes than
Nolan's Brady grounded saga the movie
follows will strong holt the son of
beloved superheroes the commander and
Jetstream as he starts his classes at
sky high a high school in the clouds
that's aimed at training the children of
supers to become the heroes of the
future the only problem will has no
superpowers which makes things tricky
when a villain takes all the super
parents out of commission and suddenly
it's on the kids of sky high to save the
day although sky high performed decently
at the box office and received generally
positive reviews
it was never truly able to establish
itself as a mainstay in the superhero
Canon perhaps after Batman Begins
viewers weren't in the right mindset for
a light-hearted campy romp or perhaps
adult audiences didn't fully connect
with the team cast whatever the reason
sky high didn't make a huge splash when
it came out and it's mostly faded from
memory however don't let its modest
performance or poor stain Power fool you
sky high is an energetic cheesy blast
filled with heartwarming friendships
high stakes adventure and charmingly
weird superpowers from characters like
the girl with the ability to transform
herself into a talking guinea pig
magenta eyes shape-shift shape-shift
into a guinea pig
great years before Nick Fury teased a
project called The Avengers initiative
and over a decade before deke who
started classes in my hero academia sky
high delivered a team of funny endearing
superheroes the whole family could enjoy
if you've never heard of the 2006
superhero themed a dramedy special you
don't need to turn in your superhero
cred card just yet barely anyone saw the
low-budget film during its limited
theatrical release as for the plot
special follows a man named les played
by Michael Rapaport who believes he's
developed superpower
after experiencing an adverse reaction
during a clinical drug trial despite
attempts from his doctor and friends to
persuade him to stop taking the drug
less becomes convinced that he was given
these powers for a reason so he sets out
to make things better for the citizens
of the town by 14 a series of small
crimes however as less gains notoriety
the company conducting the trial becomes
increasingly desperate to silence him
terrified that lesses antics will cost
them their funding while special is a
departure from standard superhero tropes
in that less only thinks he has powers
in reality he's running into walls when
he believes he's facing through them and
flailing on the floor when he thinks
explain its themes couldn't be more true
to the genre as les wrestles with
whether his powers make him special or
if he can be special without them even
when the film feels a little uneven
Rappaport's earnest performance along
with the film's unique premise makes
special truly worthy of its title
hancock follows an angry irritable
amnesiac who proves that having
superpowers doesn't necessarily make you
a hero finding himself hated by the
public for his surly disposition John
Hancock hires a public relations
specialist to rehabilitate his image as
a result he winds up not only making a
few more enemies but also discovering a
piece of information about his past that
will change his entire future despite
its solid premise and a valiant lead
effort by Will Smith the 2008 film
faltered in the execution alienating
critics with its uneven narrative and
abrupt tonal shifts what could have been
a delightfully subversive superhero
story wound up being more convoluted
than surprising with unearned twists
that strained the limits of the film's
thin internal logic still strong
performances from Smith Charlize Theron
and Jason Bateman go a long way toward
rescuing Hancock from its own worst
impulses and if you can go along with
the bizarrely contorted storytelling
there's a lot to appreciate in the
offbeat quirky script Smith checks his
charismatic charm at the door fully
embracing his off-putting character and
committing to every weird turn of the
plot but instead of pushing the audience
away he only draws us in more an [ __ ] is
far from a perfect
film but it still deserves some points
for how hard it tries between his
short-lived tenure as the Human Torch in
the Fantastic Four and his definitive
performance as Captain America MCU star
Chris Evans headlined yet another
superhero action thriller although we
don't blame anyone for forgetting about
this one
in 2009 s push Evans plays Nick a mover
who can use his telekinetic abilities to
affect the objects around him nick is
far from the only super-powered person
in his world though he's joined by Cassy
played by Dakota Fanning a watcher who
gets visions of the future and tells
Nick they must find a way to save his
ex-girlfriend kira from a variety of
super-powered enemies who will stop at
nothing to get her under their control
of course the convoluted plot of push is
far far more complicated than that
jammed so full of side characters
subplots and twists that it's easy to
get lost in its winding
adrenaline-filled corridors still
especially for MCU fans it's a lot of
fun to see Evans embody a different
character with the same inherent
likability and determination that were
so used to seeing from Steve Rogers plus
his sibling s chemistry with Fanning is
delightful to watch it's not gonna
happen okay tell me that I'm a crappy
artist and that wrong you are a crappy
artist and you all wrong sure the story
itself is more than a little bizarre and
it works hard to set up a sequel that in
all likelihood will never happen but
today's superhero fans are so used to
following intricate sprawling storylines
that it shouldn't be a problem to sit
back and enjoy the ride in the world of
animated superhero films the past 15
years have been shall we say incredible
from The Incredibles to big hero 6 -
spider-man into the spider-verse
animated films have been the source of
some of the most innovative and creative
superhero storytelling across the genre
however in the midst of this Golden Age
of animated superheroes one super film
came and went without much fanfare
despite its largely positive reviews
Megamind follows an alien supervillain
voiced by Will Ferrell who after finally
defeating the Superman like hero Metro
Man realizes his life lacks meaning and
decides to create a new hero to
battle unfortunately mega mines creation
turns out to be more villainous than
he'd intended and in order to stop him
mega mind is ultimately forced to step
into the role of hero himself it was bad
luck for Megamind that another animated
super villain turned reluctant hero film
had come out just a few months before it
hit theaters illumination entertainment
far more successful Despicable Me which
instantly took the edge off mega Minds
premise still with a first-rate cast
that also boasts the vocal talents of
Tina Fey and Jonah Hill
Megamind is a visually impressive
animated adventure that while never
completely breaking new ground is still
a fun spin on the reluctant hero trope
and is probably better than you remember
Thor the dark world didn't get the worst
reviews when it first hit theaters and
it was certainly profitable at the box
office however when asked to rank the
entries in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
the dark world tends to appear near the
bottom of most Marvel fans lists when
you stack it up against high points like
Captain America the Winter Soldier and
guardians of the galaxy the dark world
pales in comparison with a clunky script
that turns one of Thoris comic-book foes
into one of the MC use most forgettable
villains but the dark world may have
more going for it than you recall while
the first Thor painted its hero as
formal stiff and pompous the dark world
allowed him to loosen up a little
hinting at the sharp comedic turn the
series would eventually take in Thor
Ragnarok except Djoser undone the dark
world also set up the post Avengers
reconciliation between Thor and Loki
helping build the relationship between
the two brothers into one of the
strongest emotional arcs in the entire
MCU just try watching for and Loki
team-up to steal a spaceship without
cracking a smile we dare you 2009's
Defendor received only a limited
theatrical release in the u.s. it's a
shame because woody harrelson gives a
stellar heart-wrenching performance as
arthur popping ttan a man convinced that
the real world works just like the
stories in the comic books his
grandfather taught him to read every
night Arthur dresses up as the superhero
defender and goes out in search of his
arch-nemesis whom he blames for the
death of his mother while he does play
into a few of the superhero genres more
tie
tropes Defendor is mostly an
entertaining engaging film that's better
than its lack of commercial success
would suggest Harrelson's sincere
portrayal of Arthur pairs beautifully
with kat dennings trademark directness
and sandra o plays her scenes as
Arthur's court-ordered therapist with a
deep warmth and compassion that help
balance the film's darker moments
similar to the dark world Avengers age
of Ultron is the other black sheep in
the Marvel family this time the reviews
weren't all bad but the critics
definitely took points for its
inconsistent characterization disjointed
storytelling and slapdash internal logic
but although age of Ultron doesn't
manage to recreate the precise alchemy
of the Avengers it still has a few big
factors working in its favor the party
scene in which all of the Avengers try
to lift Thor's hammer feel straight out
of the comics with every character
getting to relax and showcase their
personalities in a way the previous
movies hadn't been able to fully portray
fan favorite characters the vision and
Scarlet Witch along with her brother
Quicksilver are introduced in each get
multiple moments to shine Ultron himself
is actually one of Marvel's better
villains brought to life with a
deliciously sinister vocal performance
from James Spader it even has some of
the MCU s best action hands down when
the Hulk takes on Iron Man in the second
act I'm sorry viewed alongside the rest
of the MCU it's understandable that age
of Ultron often finds itself at the
bottom of the heap but even though its
flaws are both more numerous and more
glaring than most of the films in its
company that doesn't make it bad and if
we could all be a little forgiving then
fans would see that age of Ultron is
actually a worthy entry in the MCU based
on the immensely hokey but highly
beloved 90s television series the
reimagined Power Rangers brought
together a group of just before they hit
teen actors to play the diverse group of
high-school students who are granted
superpowers in order to protect the
earth from super villain Rita Repulsa
instead of jumping straight into the
acrobatic action that characterized the
original series the film takes its time
and allowing its characters to master
their powers
in the process the Rangers develop a
closer bond with one another while
critics were largely unimpressed saying
the film failed to live up to both the
television series and other contemporary
superhero films Saban's Power Rangers
still delivered many of the things that
endeared fans to the original series
such as the strong connections between
the characters and of course the
Megazord this version of Power Rangers
may not focus as much on fight scenes
and one-liners as its predecessor but
it's still a lot of fun and its emphasis
on character / spectacle may even feel
preferable to some viewers who've grown
accustomed to the slow burn development
of the MCU based on the young adult
novel by Alexandra Bracken the darkest
minds takes place in a world in which a
mysterious virus has wiped out the
majority of the children and left the
few survivors with strange new powers in
the United States once the government
realizes what their children can do they
begin rounding all the kids up in camps
categorizing them by ability and holding
them indefinitely until the people in
power can figure out what to do with
them the darkest minds follows a group
of these children led by teen
protagonist Ruby as they attempt to make
some sense of their abilities and find a
way to live in this dangerous new world
while also remaining hidden from the
adults who are tracking them
sadly the darkest minds received mostly
negative reviews from critics and bombed
at the box office but it's worth noting
that most of its target audience seemed
to like it for fans of dystopian teen
adventures like The Hunger Games there's
plenty to like about the darkest minds
from its stirring themes of empowerment
and friendship to it's endearing
ensemble cast and four superhero fans
the x-men like power is exhibited by the
kids everything from ripping trees out
of the ground to shootin electricity
from their fingers to altering a
person's thoughts with a single touch
should be more than enough reason to
check this one out check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite films
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]